misrata is libya's third largest city
it's also one of the main sources of
military power in western libya
rebels from misrata played an important
role in the revolution that toppled
long-time leader
walmar gaddafi in 2011.
according to administrators at this
memorial museum
more than 5 000 men were killed during
the eight-month revolution
more than 30 percent of them came from
esrata
we made this museum to remember those
who sacrificed their lives for our
freedom
family members of those who were killed
come to see pictures of their relatives
and remember them as heroes
the ali hassan jabra memorial museum is
named after an al jazeera cameraman
who was killed in eastern libya while
covering the revolution in 2011.
it tells a story of victory and triumph
these statues were brought back from
gaddafi's compound after rebel forces
captured tripoli
people here in the city of misrata will
be celebrating the 10-year anniversary
to the revolution
they say that their fight in 2011 was
for freedom and democracy
but they also know all too well the cost
of war here those who died while
fighting gaddafi's forces are remembered
their pictures fill the walls ten years
on
people bring their kids here to teach
them about the conflict
february 17th means a lot to us libyans
especially here in
misrata it means freedom and democracy i
brought my kids here to show them the
picture of my nephew
and to teach them that freedom comes at
a cost medical majeure
is an engineer he lost a leg in 2011
fighting gaddafi's forces but despite
his injuries
he's now opened this health store and
works as a personal
in trainer libyans expressed themselves
and rose up against a dictator
we want a democratic state the situation
now isn't how we hoped it would be
but it will take time after 42 years
under qaddafi
it is normal that we are where we are we
hope things will get better
ten years after the revolution and this
month's political settlement
among libya's warring sides there are
hopes the fighting may end
and libya could be on track to becoming
a democratic state
malik trainer al jazeera misrata